hello I'm Carolyn levy a partner at Y
Combinator and I'm delighted to
introduce our next speaker Laura Behrens
whoo founder and CEO of Shippo Shippo
makes it easier and more - for more
affordable for e-commerce companies to
ship goods Laura and her co-founder
started Shippo in 2013 and they
currently processed millions of
shipments every month Laura had her
first experience with the startup while
working as an intern at YC alumni
company Linda she grew up in Germany
China Ecuador and Cairo went to school
in Switzerland and started Shippo in the
u.s. please welcome Laura hi ladies my
name is Laura and the CEO of a company
called Shippo let me see if this works
oh now it works great so I'm Laura I run
a company called Shippo we power
shipping for e-commerce
I am so humbled to be able to be here
today I attended every other female
founder conference before this as a
participant and I would have never
dreamed to be able to stand here on
stage today to tell you my story my
story in the last three-and-a-half years
well it's been a rollercoaster ride
there's been a lots of there's been a
lot of ups and downs but there have been
a lot of good stories to share as well
unfortunately there won't be time for
Q&A after this but this is my twitter
handle so feel free to tweet at me and I
have a couple of hours reserved after
the speech to answer all of your
questions my goal for today is to help
everyone understand that there is no
magic formula to entrepreneurship there
is no one single way how a great founder
should look like
there is no overnight success it's a lot
about hard work
it's about being persistent it's about
standing up again after you fall and I
think the most important part about
being a founder is making a decision to
get started but in order to get started
you have to have the courage you have to
have the confidence and this is one of
my favorite quotes
confidence was cash you have to have
some to get some and people were loath
to give it to you I hope with this talk
I can help you all get a little more
confident by hearing my story so what is
my story how did I get here well I did
not grow up I'm having I did not grow up
wanting to be an entrepreneur
back in 2013 I was stuck in a master's
program back in Switzerland that I did
not enjoy by pure chance I ran into a YC
alumnus who is also a Silicon Valley
investor and when he offered that he
would help me find a summer internship I
jumped on it I really didn't know what I
was getting myself into I had no idea
what Silicon Valley was like but it
sounded exciting it sounded like
something I wanted to be a part of so
I've heard chance my CV got forwarded to
the YC founder mailing list and
overnight I had a bunch of interview
requests in my inbox
it was truly about being at the right
place at the right time and they're not
shying away from taking that opportunity
I ended up with a summer internship at a
company called lendeth they do socially
responsible payday loans back then they
were right before Series A and I was I
was so in awe about the fast-paced
culture that I was Pierre Ian Singh
there I knew that I did not want to go
back so I dropped out of my grad studies
and I decided to stay staying here I
really wanted to start something
something by myself so I reached back
out to my nail co-founder Simon and
together we decided to work on an
e-commerce store it was a curated
marketplace for emerging designers and
artists from all around the world we
wanted to tell their stories this was
something that's been done before
it wasn't very innovative but we didn't
care we just wanted to get started
working on something anything and I
think that is the most important
decision that a founder can make the
decision about getting started there is
no need to overthink it you don't need
to come up with a grand idea just start
working on something on anything and
eventually you'll find the right problem
to solve so with my idea with the
e-commerce idea I approached my CEO back
then Sasha from lendeth
and asked him for his feedback for his
advice and one of the things that he
shared with me that I remember very
clearly is to work on painkillers and
not vitamins what he meant by that was
to find an idea to work on a product
that people can't live without that
solves a real pain point don't build
something that is nice to have but not
must have like him fight like a vitamin
the ecommerce store we were working on
back then was for sure a vitamin not a
painkiller but while working on the
ecommerce store we discovered how much
of a pain point shipping is to
e-commerce we realized that shipping
rates are in transparent that they're
hard to compare that shipping eats into
the margins of e-commerce donors we also
realized that shipping technologies are
difficult to integrate that they're old
and outdated working with these shipping
technologies was a very different
experience compared to working with the
technologies of Shopify or stripe and we
were surprised that there was no stripe
for shipping so that's what we set out
to build chapeau is an API that connects
our customers or e-commerce stores
marketplaces and platforms to a network
of different shipping providers we out
them get access to that network we help
them optimize providers we help them get
we help them get shipping labels get
tracking numbers in short we take the
pain out of shipping we turn shipping
into a competitive advantage instead of
a cost center so now that we had an idea
that we thought was worth working on we
had to get funded both my co-founder and
I are first-time founders we didn't have
any savings so we had to rely on outside
capital to make this work I guess
everyone here in this room is either
seeking funding now or will be seeking
funding at some time at some point in
the future so let me share my
fundraising story with you my
fundraising story is a lot about
rejection we applied to Y Combinator and
we got rejected we applied to 500
startups and we got rejected as well we
applied another time and we got lucky
and got into a 500 startups patch aid
the reason why we wanted to be part of
an accelerator is to get access to their
network of investors so we can so we
could raise a series
seed for the serious seed I pitched a
hundred and twenty-five angels and
investors and I heard a hundred and
fifty nose in the end we raised two
million dollars from ten investors
that's a whole lot of nose to go through
before we got the two million together
and to be honest we pushed a lot of the
wrong VCS
we pitched VCS that weren't the right
fit either because they weren't the
right fit for the stage that we were in
or for the space that Shippo is in but I
don't regret pitching all these
investors practice really makes perfect
at the end of pitching all these people
I had my pitch nailed down and when we
finally met the right investors and you
exactly what to say all investors tend
to ask the same kinds of questions so at
the end of this I knew the answers to
all these questions by heart
while going through that fundraise
unfortunately we had to go separate ways
with our third co-founder and that's the
kind of situation that can kill a deal
easily in that situation I also for the
first time learned about the power of
being transparent and straightforward
with prospective investors we
communicated that change right away
upfront direct and honest and we also
communicated that this was the kind of
we also set the expectation right that
this was the kind of communication style
they could be expecting us moving
forward if they do end up if they do
decide to invest and in the end we were
able to close around from the same
investors despite the change in the
founding team leading up to the series
seed we were growing our business 40%
week over week and that was in terms of
shipping volume I think one of the most
important pieces of advice we got back
then was to focus on one single KPI to
find one KPI that defines success for
your business best and to focus on
growing that one instead instead of like
getting overwhelmed by all the other
metrics out there today of course we're
optimizing a bunch of other metrics as
well but shipping volume is still earn
is still our main KPI for the series a
we did a lot better
we were able to get 30 warm
introductions to investors we were able
to set the time line and drive the time
line ourselves instead of having
investors driving that means that we set
one week up for first meetings a second
week for second meetings one week for
partner meetings and then another week
for due diligence it was important for
us that we had everyone lined up at the
same pace so at the end of this process
we would be able to get to competitive
term sheets and at the end we raised
seven million dollars from Union Square
Ventures so from the outside it looked
like a really tight run and smooth
process but behind the scenes a lot was
going wrong again we again had to go
separate ways with our back then most
senior technical leader and guess what
we got our first [ __ ] lawsuit during
due diligence wait once won back yeah we
got our first [ __ ] lawsuit during
due diligence who would have thought
like that was really crazy
well anyway again we were able to we
were able to use that situation to like
to use that bad situation and turn it
into into an opportunity to build trust
build trust with the prospective
investors by communicating clearly
thoughtfully indirectly and I think like
you're going to build a long-term
relationship with that investor
investors are like employees that you
can fire they're going to stick around
until until there is a liquidity event
so you better turn the table around and
do due diligence on your prospective
investors as well because you want to be
able to expect the same kind of
integrity from them investors will be
well they'll be fast to offer you
references but make sure that you also
do back-channel references and you that
you're able to talk to people - founders
that have worked with this investor when
they failed you want to know how the
investor behaves when things go wrong so
but from pitching all these people my
most important takeaways are be it be
authentic be passionate and be honest
and I think the one thing that US female
founders are really good at is to under
but to over-deliver and that's a great
characteristic to be known for then
there are some situations while pitching
that are just totally out of your
control weird things happen but they
make for great stories to tell later on
one of my favorite stories to tell is
how I went into a partner meeting at
Kleiner Perkins well a lot of decliner
partners were attending including John
doar all the kleiner partners were at
one side of the table and I was at the
other side of the table as the only
person there I said right across the
table of John doar we had our super
engaged conversation I felt great about
it it was intense it was a lot of
back-and-forth but I was excited I felt
like I was able to answer all of their
questions very well at the very end of
this conversation when we were starting
to wrap things up John doar leaned
forward
he pushed forward his note notepad and
pen and he said to me Laura draw me a
picture of your team and I was so
confused I did not know what he wanted
from me I thought this could be some
sort of psychology trick question or
he's going to look into you know if I
draw myself bigger than all my other
team members that gonna mean that I'm
eager centric or maybe if I draw myself
gender-neutral that could mean that I'm
not confident in my own skin so I
decided to draw a little stick figure
girl complete with a dress long hair and
a smiley face and I was just about to
start drawing my other team members what
I realized people in the room were
laughing I looked up and John doar was
smiling at me he was like Laura all I
was looking for was an org chart
yeah I that happened it's a real story I
felt like a complete [ __ ]
and then afterwards whenever I go into
the kleiner office they're they know me
as the stick figure girl anyway stuff
like that happens it happens to anyone
and these make these make for great
stories to tell don't worry too much
about it when stuff like that happens to
you so today we are 70 people all
working out of her San Francisco office
we have six thank you we have 16,000
customers and we've been able to triple
our business in terms of shipping volume
every single year since we started we're
still growing we're still hiring however
I still don't have everything figured
out yet and I think when people tell you
that they have everything figured out
they're lying
however there are a bunch of really
great learnings that have impacted my
life for the better in the last couple
of years and I want to share a couple of
my favorite learnings with you first of
all it's a marathon and not a sprint in
fact I think it's more like it's more
like one of these crazy 100-mile races
that only insane people sign up to do
it's going to be a lot of ups and downs
and sometimes these ups and downs happen
from one hour to another 1-hour yours
you receive a term sheet the other hour
you receive a lawsuit during these ups
and downs it's important to keep in mind
that your company worth is not equal to
your self-worth and I think that is easy
to forget here in Silicon Valley because
whenever you go out and socialize people
are going to ask you what is your
company how much money have you raised
how who are your investors and then
they're going to judge you by that but
keep in mind that you are more than your
company's success
don't let that define you while going
through all these ups and downs it's
important to remain persistent
however persistence does not mean being
stubborn
I think it's important to be persistent
about the right things and what has
worked for us really well is to be
persistent about the goals but to be
creative and fly
Sybil's about the tactics of how to get
there there will be times when you think
that you are failing when a failure
happens to me what I like to do is to
take a step back and look at the look at
the big picture I like to treat that one
point of failure as a piece for a big
puzzle and then try to see what the big
puzzle will look like sometimes that
takes a couple of years before you'll
you'll be able to see the bigger picture
but I think failure leads to new
opportunities opportunities that
wouldn't have been there otherwise for
example I was super devastated when we
got rejected by YC back then but I'm
still standing on stage here today and
everything that happened in between was
great I wouldn't have wanted it any
other way my second point is all about
you
beyond apologetic about who you are be
authentic be yourself there are so many
expectations about what the perfect
founder should look like and what the
perfect female founder should look like
I used to try to be like Steve Jobs or
Mark Zuckerberg but that's ridiculous
and impossible because I'm Laura and I'm
proud of that and I think it's like it's
completely fine not to be great at
everything but you need to know your
strengths and your weaknesses and then
you'll be able to hire four
complementary skills being unapologetic
also means that you won't be able to
work with everyone having clicker
problems yeah
that you won't be able to work with
everyone and again that's completely
fine better a hole in the organization
than an [ __ ] in the organization
this is your company that you're
building and your defining company
culture don't end up building a company
that you'll hate working at five years
from now you can be completely
unapologetic
about the kind of culture that you want
to build at your own company that also
means to hire slow and to fire fast my
next point again is about you a lot of
people think when you start a company
you need to sacrifice everything for
your company and I agree it's about a
lot of hard work it's about being
persistent and all those other things
but you need to take the time to take
care of yourself because taking care of
yourself is taking care of your company
at the very beginning you are your
company make sure that you know what
gives you energy and what drains you and
then do less of what drains you there is
no bad boss that you can blame for being
miserable it's up to you if you're not
happy you're the one who can drive that
change taking care of yourself also
means it's completely okay to ask for
help
in fact it's smart to ask for help I've
been fortunate to have that I have a
great group of investors that are super
supportive that I have an amazing
executive coach that I have an amazing
group of friends that I can relate to I
love hanging out with other CEOs and
founders because hanging out with them
teaches me that the struggle said I'm
going through are completely normal that
they've gone through the same struggles
as well that these struggles aren't
unique to me but that they're just part
of normal startup life the autumn or
personal note last year I made this
great decision to adopt this grumpy
looking cat
she's really the grumpiest at sir that's
for everyday face and when I come home
from work and things aren't going that
well because we're not shipping enough
packages I see her face and everything
is a little better again more important
than my relationship with my cat is my
relationship with my co-founder Simon
sometimes we fight but we never get hurt
permanently my co-founder Simon well
he's 100% complimentary to my skills
he's able to do all the things that I
can't do or don't like to do and he does
them really well I wouldn't be able to
be here without him
so find yourself a partner in crime for
me it's a partner in shipping to share
the burden of running a company with you
Simon's been supportive through the ups
and downs both of my private life both
of my work life and in my private life
Simon's the one I called when I was
going through a bad breakup
and he was the one who brought me a
bottle of whisky he was also the one who
remembered to take the bottle of whisky
away from me when he left and that was
important because next morning at 7 a.m.
I had a recorded podcast interview where
I was supposed to tell how awesome it is
to be a founder and I do think it is
awesome to be a founder however it also
means that you're going to be one of the
few females in a male-dominated industry
and given that we're at a female founder
conference today I think it's important
to acknowledge the brave women that have
been speaking up in the last couple of
months to drive change into this
industry
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I've been lucky that I've never
experienced direct sexual harassment
like that
however I've gotten used to being one of
them I've gotten used to being one of
the few females in the room especially
I'd be to be CEO dinners somehow they're
not that many b2b female founders and
many times when I'm outside of the
office and people ask me what I do for
ship oh they're surprised to hear that
I'm the founder and CEO and I never
quite understand why what did they
expect the founder and CEO of ship Oh
should look like there was one time when
I was pitching a male a male VC for my
series aim and after the pitch his first
comment was this is a cute little
business you've built and there is
really nothing cute about a shipping API
so I used to hate I used to hate talking
about being a female founder I used to
hate being put into that box I disliked
being part of these female founder lists
because the market really does not care
if this company is run by a female or
not customers choose to go with the
product that's best and I want to ship
out to to be the best period independent
of my gender I used to live by the
mantra to be so good that they can't
ignore you in the last in the last year
my attitude to that has changed a little
I realized it's naive to believe that if
you work really hard you won't be
discriminated I realized I realized that
I realized that it's not always on the
woman to prove themselves it's a problem
with a system and good news is that we
everyone here in this room is able to
make a difference we can make a
difference by starting companies and
building company cultures that women
enjoy working at we can make a
difference by being role models for the
next generation of female entrepreneurs
and me we can make a difference by
generating outstanding returns for the
investors that have placed a bet on us
and I'm excited for everyone here to
help us make that
friends
[Applause]
[Music]
I could keep talking about this
endlessly but I'm running out of time
and there is still so much to do so much
to learn I want to leave you with one
final quote if you're following your
calling the fatigue will be easier to
bear the disappointments will be fuel
the highs will be like nothing you've
ever felt and I hope that you find your
calling and I hope that when you find
your calling you take that opportunity
so best of luck everyone
and feel free to tweet at me with any
questions that you have thank you
[Applause]
you